epicurious.com is I think probably the
best food website out there it's got
more Awards than any other website I
will doubt it for that and it's
comprised of 60,000 recipes 25,000 of
which are from some of the best food
magazines in the business gourmet and
Bon Appetit magazine as well as
thousands of recipes from cookbook
authors and chefs from around the world
it also has 35,000 recipes from our
members and people from around the world
have input their own recipes into our
database and people can rate and review
those recipes and comment on them and
it's an amazing community that's been
fostered at epicurious so it's actually
one of the first social networking sites
that was out there because it was really
one of the first sites where you could
talk about food wait food review it be
your own critic you know the criticism
from the community the the pans the
waves all of that added a real editorial
layer to the site that a site had never
been created before like that so it's
very unique in that in that way it also
has a really rich layer of editorial
authoritative guide so every holiday
from lunar new year through Christmas
Day we've got you covered menus recipes
we do amazing technique videos so for
people who don't know how to cook or how
to cook an egg or even pop open a
champagne bottle we've got everything
you would need to know about doing all
of those things from the very simple to
the very complicated so we really try to
just talk about food for people who love
to eat and embrace food and we don't try
to preach to them we try to talk to
people who don't know how to cook as
well as we will really love to cook so
we're talking to a lot of different
audiences
the recipes that are the editorial
recipes on our site come from gourmet
and Bon Appetit Bon Appetit magazines
from Self magazine from parade and also
from some of the best cookbooks from
around the world so one of the things
that we do all the time is look for
quickbooks that are coming out from
acclaimed authors and we always choose
some recipes to put up in the database
from curries to tagines to you know pace
in the blankets so we really try to kind
of cover the gamut of things and we also
do a lot of web exclusive recipes that
we asked chefs and recipe developers to
create for us exclusively for ever
curious so we have thousands of those so
it's a real big gamut of professionally
tested recipes and the great thing about
epicurious is that any of those recipes
any of the 25,000 that are in the
database have all been tested so that
you know that each recipe will be a
success for you it's we've they've been
tested multiple to it of time so that
way you can really be assured that you
know if you're going to make a chocolate
cake for the first time you don't need
to make it six times to get it to work
in fact it will work the first time
these generated recipes we do not test
there are so many of them there you know
to date we have 35,000 of them so we
don't test them but we do look over them
and we actually choose some that as
editors we think are particularly good
and we highlight those on the site all
of the recipes that the member database
has can all be rated and reviewed so
people do review each other's recipes
and it's very interesting to see the
comments they take it as seriously as
they do the editorial recipes on
epicurious so they will say you know I
made your recipe Annie and it was
fantastic but I took a lot less you know
butter and cream I instead I used were
caught it there's something like that
it's very instructive I think that
ninety percent of the people that use
epicurious recipes in fact do read
almost all the comments to gain kind of
more knowledge that said there are some
recipes on the site that have 800
comments so obviously you're not going
to read all of them but there are ninety
percent or ninety-five percent at this
point of the recipes on epicurious have
been rated and reviewed by people